ある日のこと
俺は見つけてしまった
こどもも大人もみんなで月はコーナー
そんなガチャコーナーの一角にとんでもねえものを見つけちまったんだ
衝撃のガチャ降臨いろんなガチャでますこのフォントで神域ではなく衝撃を統一して
いるあたりに長作県への効力が感じられるこの時これは思ってしまったんだ
何が入っているんだろう
ちょっと回してるかなと思いますね
いいましたん
浜田大丈夫いや何かありますかねえっ
ええええええ
ていた
集まってましたこの時俺はまだ知らなかった
どこれがいくつあるみたい
様がいていますその日初めは思い出した
残りのガチャの数の恐怖
あと4つが5つぐらい
凌駕してくれはい渡りお会いしてきましたわれ500円だものとなっちまっ人の次で
ラストですもう一歩などを促していきます
て来なかった
これはまじかまじかまじかな子かこうやってまたも3回以来あの手の停車に uv
データございますから始めます
ん
ちょっと多いかなっちゃったのはない使ったんだろう1個200円ですよこの後で
1000円ですからね天に星安全4000旺盛6000あ7000
あこの時はじめは思った
考えるの
やめよモーゼ第一の合図を使ってるんですけども衝撃のガチャ何が入ってるかわかん
ないガチャの中身を全部知りたくてかなり気持ちでやったら本でもでことになっちまっ
たあのこれでねまあ世の中の謎が一つでも途切れなら僕はいいよ彼は無いさぁ中身が何
か分からないガザガザノン中身全部でこのマン番だったんで多分誰も買わなかったん
でしょうか
y さんの子達ですよまだ中身を見てないんでちょっと1個ずつ見ていきましょう
これにしましょうまず1個目はいえーと姫ちゃんの姫ちゃんのリボン1個目はこれでし
た
わー
なんかはいいなぁ
次来ましたモモタロスだこれで仮面ライダーでようなキャラクターなんですよこれは
すごくで仮面ライダー電王のキャラのモモタロスですこれはすごくないですか
便を見てないけどねつぎ存知これガンダムですねあの
作るタイプですねめんどくさいから今日は嫌すぎ
をワームもうご飯きましたもうもう
メラルーのストラップとモフモフがついてますこれこそ
に100円以上の価値があるみたいなやつそろそろ出てきてもいいと思うんですけど
三役ジャンパーいた武家ちょっと右上帰省中見てたからこれは嬉しいとやったやった
ここに来てちょっといいのがきましたよ右でせ at なぁ
これで200円かこれは誰コップ口この友達の花弁が系の人々仮面で気さえさん48歳
ピアノコースをしている主婦の方ですね壁だけ再三だとこういう感じちょっと壁をね
貫通することができるみたいですもう2パパと行くよ
このうケップ人のサラリーマンがしてでこういう感じらしいですよ
なんか
悲しいね今の社会を表してるよアプリのキャラクターの豆らしいです感謝なこれもその
パターンじゃれも同じアプリの客さんでしたよなら空いた穴にみんな坊主じゃん大家
ました
うわぁ
初めてポイントさんちょっとまずほんとさぁストがそろそろこれはどうだ
ショッカーが仮面ライダーのショッカーじゃんおっ
入っちゃったこれまたガンダムだ右からにかっこいいぞめんどくさー次はこちらもねを
もうアーマーたこのパターンがバブルな空気持ってる
ダメないコミュニティガイドラインにひっかけこちらこれも山これやるタイプで売り
残ってるのかなーぜこちらに待っておっ
海未ちゃ海未ちゃぷめちゃラブライブ入ってさあこれは俺の基礎月2000円へ走って
だねーくると嬉しいですね
ああああそなんだこれも仮面ライダー電王の人だった
ああおっしゃあ気合だけだエアー内校
いやーやはりあーやー何でこの子だってのちょっとよくわかんないんですけど茶なら次
いきますこれは間にこうでしょ
かわいいなんだこれおみくじをしておみくじ
はいうんまぁ全部だまずは2のぜひの死んだときのプレートやでも嬉しいな混ざって
好きだから
わー同じでクラシック小継これまで同じだ
3つ目でこの黒い中身っていうのはなんか気になるよね搬送
ううううううっ
あーめんどくさいつギア貼っていきますよはいホイのにこれあれだ俺もの方にですね俺
物語のスタンプだ
優勝これなんだヲタ芸だこのいろんなハッピーのある中野翠ハッピーがてだと逸れた+
まだまだありますよ次
布ダメって影スマホのおふとんのラバからですね
勘弁してくれよあああ細い棺の
もう見るからに何だ何これスマホの罰バーガーもなめとんのかさあ笹次は
山崎シゲルさんなんだこれ知ってるぞ
めちゃくちゃ足が長いねこれ twitter よく見るんですよね
絶対めんどくさいやつかぶったさっきのやツアークロスボーンガンダム買っちゃな
ブーブー
顔するんだ
ブーバーこれもう完全に仮面ライダーこれダメ200
援助の活動あると次恋とエッジ没
ワンパンマン10月パター
ブーバーデイリーぺ25ああっもうブーブープープーうーん
あっはい多いパーツが入っを待ってドラッグへ感がある被って可愛い桜
スライムだこれすごいかわいいシャア雨だドライブカメラれたドライバーがバイクが
当たりました以上
功労よっ
価格なにこれパンかつじゃん待て待てを刺しじゃねーかはい神社ですこれで4つ目です
ねそろそろいい加減にしてほしいものです何だこれは
mars んだいやいい波きてるよでもなんかねえ
面白いの多いねやっぱこれはあっあるっちゃすげー
3ダーダー惚れ覚えてる
懸命ふざけ合って re
あっあっこういう時が危ないからねさんこれマって多いねさんだ
なんでマーキングしたんだろうプレッシャー4これは山崎くーん
ハーイ子にカメラれたドライブがバーン
あーちょっとしんどい次これは彼は絶対ホラー
亜子完全に考えるでしょ関東に考えるでしょ
ホイップ
次これなんなこれ物語ああ
ああなんだ俺も方に良いまたキター
はいっまた嫌な予感が
さっきのハンカチーフ浮かぶったこれは使えるこれが最後ですよ
1万円以上使ってガチャって行った主目ですからね
何が入ってるでしょあっ
かもよと言い何が誰かわかんない勝ち方だったんですけども
一番の数はないかな
長間でも非常によってね欲しいものが違うんで僕は足が中で猫2匹とラブライブ梅
ちゃんとこの火山後 bb ですね来なかっただけで3番抽選分の価値あるんですけど
なにがでるかわかんないかあさんのひみつまだ7解けたんで裏風呂でよかったなと思い
ます皆
ガチャは保護にねじゃん
web
しています